when i was a kid any time i ever heard  of any dude hitting a chick i ruled it  as dishonorable and i would never talk  to that person but now  i was like this is the one you want to  go with he sets it up like i think it's  a great idea  notice all of us started backing up  it's the most honorable thing you can do  to put it out there since i've switched  my belief i have never hit any chicks  ever  [ __ ]  you won't do it cause as i got older  i've seen chicks push dudes they hit me  and they're like hitting them right and  me seeing that and the dude actually lay  one hand down and then drop the chick  that's what exactly what you're asking  for also  and also  continue this is going really well so  what time where  there we go let's see if i found out  anthony hit his chicks just say nick  just say nick